Dear LeBron
I'm sorry this had to happen this way
That I didn't tell you sooner
Claiming the O'Brien Throne with you
was one of the proudest moments of my life
And I will be forever grateful for the lessons you've taught me
But I can no longer fight in your shadow
Sure, we had our differences
But the real problem
is that we're very much the same
Many men succumb to the allure of rings and superteams
only to obscure a deeper desire
to be The Man
While this chapter comes to a close
a new door is opened
beyond which lies the knowledge of my true potential
I may find that I was mistaken
That I needed you all along
Or maybe I'll discover
that I am more powerful than I ever dreamed
And so I've set sail for the edge of the world
But if I find that this world is indeed round
then maybe one day
my journey will lead me back to you
In my stead awaits another
You may recall his words from last year
Well, his wish has been granted
There will be...
A new...
King in the East
King James is late to his own meeting
Doesn’t bode well for us getting out of this slump
Hopefully he’s finalizing a trade for Kevin
Am I right?
Freakin' Kevin
What is that?
That's odd
Some sort of pregnant raven
Oh no...
WOJ BOMB!! OH SH-